こんにちははじめ社長ですあの僕昔スノーの総会したと思うんですよあの写真とでる
やつで久しぶりに使ってみたらですね結構色々増えてまして
かわいい写真だけじゃなくて行動物と加工面白いやつとかこれだけなんか色んな
エフェクトだったら僕なんか一人で前約できるんじゃないかなと思ってへとちょっと
俊一をつけてみました
ポストの散歩ですどうぞ
多い
ポーチ散歩行こうぜ次恋は
は
凄いぜ
はーやーぽっち今日も天気がいいなぁ
うわぁ
そっかぽつも声に行きたいかあ場所はさせました
在校際早速ぬーぬーん姫君ご機嫌4なって使わちゃお久しぶりです
こっちは今日も元気なはにペってたぁー
[音楽]
ぼっちついたぞうーん
見てこの墓地いろんな動物いるよああっ
par
me
んはぶらし
ピョンピョンピョン
re
car
あああああうわあ
俺だ俺だ俺だうわぁ俺だねっ
防具
ちゃったから叩くんじゃねーよゐこえー
[音楽]
ああああああ
いかがだったでしょうか
ああいうわけでも普通に起動ことよりこれだけたくさんのイベントがあるっていうこと
僕が伝えたかったでございます2にスノーで寝ちゃっきーのがありまして
まあを可愛いね例えばってとるんですか
って.ですねチャットに誰より送ることができます例えば here にょこのまま今
送りました
もうスマートな
チャットのやり取りもできるし画像のをクリアもできるでございます何コレ
長尾背中をくれるのか
葉は youtube これでも遅れてんだね5連として溢れてるじゃん多そう凄い
凄いこれじゃ
をエフェクトをかけたらこれで送れるということです
浜口国を凄い凄い是永一寸でこういう感じで送れるポイント
親分ごめんなさいチャット機能ですね全てブドウが儲けるしか雑木ででして文章を気軽
におけるんでぜひぜひ皆さん活用してみてはいかがでしょうか
なんか久しぶりにやったら作れてだいぶ面白かった
うん代わり自分で崎もザリーナたいときで皆さんするの久しぶりにやると目指し色だ
けど増えていたのでぜひ皆さんも遊んでみたい方でしょうか
最後で最高に可愛い則っておりましょう
かわいいなマジでが悪いん可愛いは作れる
じゃあ
me
あっはっ